the Sheldon is very close
the wreckage of Russian Vehicles is
littering this street it's full of sweet
here we go it started before Dawn
look at that Mark
[Music]
it's the only way out of European and
this would test even the fit and healthy
but those still fleeing are the most
vulnerable the elderly the frail and the
very young there's no water no
electricity they're still hanging on I
don't know how they're doing it but they
are they are going west to safety he
will now Head East to fight there is
going to be one Almighty Crush as people
try to get on
rods going up behind you now
whatever fell from the sky made a crater
this big
[Music]
Crawford from Sky News claw the sky and
stop bombing don't don't speak about the
bureaucratic steps
it's a professional Ambush the bullets
just don't miss
oh
hi
find the next the five of us have made
it out of the car down the embankment
and we just can't believe we're alive
good evening from the Ukrainian Capital
cave
see what's left of the missile here the
words on the side of that zadeti it
means four children the train station
was packed with people trying to find a
way out this is what it's like in
come on
a mass grave here triggered Global
horror
these boys are out every day protecting
their Village but what's left of it with
their own checkpoint and toy guns
at first we were scared really scared
but now we are ready to fight
fights like hell so through here the
making the molotov cocktails
Vladimir Putin thought that Russian
forces would capture Kiev within days
they failed
instead his forces are bogged down in a
war
that that unwilling to leave and so far
incapable of winning this is absolutely
incredible we're on the outskirts of
Kirsten
we've been given a military escort
and as you can see people are absolutely
beautiful
finally leopard two tanks are coming
from Europe you must be relieved
[Music]
in war it is always the children
always the children displaced
always the children without a say in
what adults are doing to their world